[Musique]
les deux carburants sont produits à
partir d'huile végétale et d'huile
viennent de déchets ou de résidus et
aujourd'hui en 2023 on fait évoluer
notre installation industrielle pour
traiter jusqu'à 70% de ses déchets et
résidus
c'est très important pour nous d'aller
sur le terrain pour voir comment chacun
peut contribuer et voir le potentiel
d'innovation qui existe tout se passe
pas depuis Paris et ce ne sont pas
uniquement les pouvoirs publics qui
peuvent demain trouver ce genre de
solution pour assurer une des
carbonations du secteur des transports
du secteur de l'industrie
[Musique]
on identifié c'est d'essayer de
convertir l'huile à l'intérieur du
corail en hydrocarbure
aujourd'hui il y a déjà un marché qui
existe pour la valorisation des
molécules issues des microaggues mais
qui reste un marché de niche à haute
valeur ajoutée et pour tout ce qui est
biocarburant qui est une filière
vraiment en cours de développement il y
a encore besoin de développement de
recherche de recherche fondamentale et
de recherche technologique pour tout ce
qui est notamment monter en maturité
on est dans un monde qui évolue mon
innovation et la transition écologique
doit pouvoir s'appuyer sur le
biocarburant le carburant synthétique
synthétique durable et l'hydrogène vert
notre questionnement au sein de la
mission c'est de savoir comment demain
tout ceci peut s'organiser
[Musique]